so last week nintendo kind of broke the
internet when they announced that steve
from minecraft was coming to smash
but i'm here to tell you that he
actually looks pretty cool
and kind of powerful
all right folks before we get into steve
i want to make sure that you're all
subbed to the channel
subs really do help us out and so do
likes on this video and comment
if you don't know what to leave a
comment about then just tell us what you
want to see us make a video about next
whether it's donate me a story of
shorts whatever and if it's too long for
the comments then send us an email at
tips at thescore.com
okay so over the past few entries
nintendo has been expanding smash bros
past
just nintendo characters and in smash
ultimate
they've been adding third-party
characters at a pretty insane rate
but still nobody really expected
minecraft's team
i'm so clueless no
oh my
oh they god minecraft steve in his game
there were of course some people who
were less pumped about the reveal
i don't can't believe it i'm going to
turn the stream off right now
and some people were genuinely upset
someone sent me this facebook post where
this guy wrote
i've gotten less and less into video
games as i got older and probably only
play video games like once or twice a
year
now that minecraft is in super smash
brothers i think i can say that video
games are officially dead
i don't think i'll ever play a video
game again video games are no longer a
thing that exists
it was fun while it lasted rip video
games and [ __ ] you if you're younger
than me
i hate oh wait that's bait
but like there are some people out there
who are genuinely upset
obviously not to the degree of that
insane fake troll post
but there are folks out there who don't
like that steven minecraft is taking up
one of the few precious character slots
in smash
this bros i hate it no
i feel like the argument against steve
in smash is that he
is kind of a meme that he is this like
silent avatar who represents minecraft
and he's not a character
which fair sure but like mario and link
don't exactly have personalities either
but i think the biggest
problems that people have with steve and
smash is one
minecraft is a super popular game that's
probably bigger than smash
so it might feel a little bit
uncomfortable to stick him in there
and on top of that he doesn't fit in the
same way that the other third party
characters do
sonic snake even joker all made sense
next to nintendo characters
but steve kind of sticks out like a sore
thumb plus there could be some concern
that minecraft kids are gonna overrun
smash bros and ruin it or something but
i just don't think that's gonna happen
generally speaking i agree that steve
doesn't really fit into smash but i
think that's actually a good thing
and i think that if a bunch of minecraft
fans get exposed to smash and become
smash fans that's
also only good so what's the deal here
why did nintendo put steve into smash
when he doesn't really
fit in the game how does he work well
nintendo actually gave steve a pretty
insane kit
he doesn't really play by the rules of
smash all that much and
he has some really unique crazy
abilities to start
keep minds just like in minecraft if you
press b without pressing a direction
steve will mine
the nearest wall or floor or ceiling for
materials like
wood iron and stone then you use that
material to build stronger weapons to
fight with and tools to mine with
i know that literally sounds like how
you play minecraft but it actually
transfers over to smash pretty cleanly
as you dig you put all the materials you
collect into a resources meter which
looks extremely confusing but basically
boils down to how much of each resource
you have for building when steve spawns
into a match he gets a crafting table
and that sits wherever it is until steve
pressed
shield and b at the same time which
teleports the crafting table to him when
you're standing from the crafting table
you can press
b and you'll automatically craft the
strongest weapon you can craft
that depends on the materials you have
and we'll get to that in a bit
anyway you can also use the materials
you collect for the third attack
associated with this neutral b move
create block if you're in the air and
you press b then you'll make a block
immediately beneath you which you can
stand on for a few seconds before it
breaks
you can also hold it down to keep
putting down blocks as you
walk in the air you'll use whatever the
weakest material you have to build
blocks so you'll start with i think
sand then dirt then stone etc but the
point is the stronger the material is
the longer it'll take for the block to
break
and this is actually where steve starts
to break the rules a little bit
because steve can basically use blocks
to just stop in mid-air he can stop
certain recoveries
no why pica
and he can use his blocks to set up
insane edge guards that literally no
other character can do
dreadful i agree
you understand what this means now for
his weapons
steve's attacks involve his minecraft
weapons swords
axes pickaxes that kind of stuff using
attacks with those weapons uses up their
durability and once they're out of
durability they'll break
higher tier materials make more durable
stronger weapons like
iron is more durable than wood but some
stuff like gold makes a more fragile but
more powerful weapon he also has other
attacks that use up materials he can
drop an iron anvil or make a tnt block
or make minecart rails out of gold and
redstone
but if you try to use those attacks
without having enough materials for them
you'll get either weaker versions of
them or
sometimes nothing at all so steve is
obviously bringing a ton of new things
to smash and he's pretty hard to
evaluate but
it seems like he can do it all but he
does have some weaknesses his range
kinda looks like crap to be honest he is
going to get out spaced by a lot of the
top tiers and ultimate and he
also doesn't really have any way to
fight fire with fire when it comes to
projectiles and
aside from blocks his offstage game
seems pretty weak
his jumps are very low and his upbeat
leaves him really vulnerable he also
looks really vulnerable when he's mining
you can retreat a little bit when you're
doing it but given how much time it
takes to get the good stuff
it looks like you're mostly going to be
mining for resources after you've
already knocked your opponent off stage
which
is going to be easier to do once you've
gotten resources also since creating a
block offstage requires resources in the
first place there's going to be a little
bit of attention here you're going to
have to make a choice between knocking
your opponent off stage and mining or
knocking your opponent off stage and
going for the crazy offstage block
down smash play but at the end of the
day it's gonna be about the numbers
in smash 4 cloud charged up limit
insanely fast and before he got nerfed
joker charged up our sen really quickly
too if launch minecraft steve has quick
mining
he's gonna be a lot stronger than he
would be otherwise just imagine playing
a character that denies like
half the cast recoveries sure pikachu is
a given and he's pretty good
but characters like mario sonic captain
falcon they're all gonna have to think
twice about how their recovery is gonna
go when steve has resources
and there are some characters out there
who can't recover at all if steve can
put down blocks
mind you they're mostly low tiers so
nobody really cares
gonna cry we also don't really know much
about steve's kill power
sure he looks like he can combo certain
things together pretty well but can he
actually close out a stalk steve is also
bringing another really
interesting dimension to competitive
play when steve minds the materials he
gets are
different based on the surfaces he's
mining so on a rocky stage he's getting
stone
on a dirt path he's getting dirt
everything
seems to be available everywhere but the
rate at which you get certain materials
varies from stage to stage
so all of a sudden there could be an
interesting counterpick decision when it
comes to what stage you want to fight
steve on do you pick a stage that gives
him a lot of wood but denies him a lot
of stone and iron or do you give him a
stage that has a ton of stone but keeps
him off stuff like
gold and diamonds i don't actually know
if any of that is going to end up
mattering but it could be a really
really cool extra dimension to his
metagame look it's hard to see if any of
this will actually help steve given his
apparent weaknesses
but the thing is i think he looks really
cool i think he is a really fun addition
to smash
he turns kirby all minecraft and kirby
swallows him that's awesome
i kind of hope he's competitively viable
and i really hope that evo next year is
an
all minecraft steve top eight that's
what the world deserves
i'm not a mike i mean listen it's gonna
be hard to take me off a joker a
character i really like and a character
that's broken
i also haven't played smash in months
now
um aside from playing a little bit with
my girlfriend like i just haven't played
like tournament rules or whatever
because i have no one to play it with
and online is terrible
like smack playing smash online is among
the worst experiences i've ever played
in my life i play a lot of fighting
games online and fighting game netcode
is pretty much terrible across the board
but smash takes the cake it's like
playing fighting games underwater with
like weight strapped to your ankles
it sucks when you're playing like 1v1 no
items like that's bad enough
but there are modes where you play eight
players items
on online and it's just how did anyone
experience this [ __ ] like
slideshow and enjoy it how did anyone
play this game that runs at two frames a
minute
and lags for eight years and be like yes
this is what we're gonna have people pay
for an online service and a 90 video
game to play
this is what they wanted